c'est une tempête d'une rare violence la
plus forte depuis 50 ans qui a frappé la
partie nord du pays cette nuit mais
aussi paris et l'île de france
pour l'instant le bilan toujours
provisoire est de 27 morts en france
deux disparus et des dizaines de blessés
graves
jacques chirac le président de la
république en vacances au maroc a
adressé cet après midi ses condoléances
ou factices aux familles des victimes
fait exceptionnel jean tiberi le maire
de paris demande les que l'état de
catastrophe naturelle soit déclaré dans
la région parisienne
les vents avoisiner 150 km/heure et
certains quartiers de paris offrait ce
matin un spectacle de désolation comme
ont pu le constater olivier caroff fanni
au vernis christian leroux et jacques
girard la tempête a emporté tout ce qui
faisait obstacle à sa course folle dans
les rues rien n'a résisté à même les
engins ni plus lourd
une force inouïe qui pendant deux heures
ce matin jeter bas tout ce qui n'était
pas assez solide les cheminées les
arbres pas un quartier de paris qui
n'était épargné
ici un morceau de façade arraché le toit
les pompiers ont sorti deux blessés
graves de cet amas de débris
là c'est une grue qui s'est effondré les
habitants l'ont vivacité impuissant elle
est tombée et heureusement il ya une
tempête qui a érigé ces barrages un peu
partout dans la capitale
compliquant encore la tâche des services
de secours
dix mille interventions en quelques
heures pour les pompiers de la région
parisienne
des numéros d'urgence totalement saturé
d'appels il a fallu parer au plus pressé
dégager des axes de circulation pour
pouvoir intervenir dans cet immeuble
d'argenteuil il n'y avait
malheureusement plus rien à faire un
couple qui vivait au dernier étage a été
écrasé par les dates de la toiture
seules leurs enfants a pu être souvent
troisième juge dando j'ai entendu un
gros boum en 3 4 secondes et à tous les
murs fissurés ou quoi dans cet hôtel
d'euro disney on compte six blessés
graves encore un toit qui s'est effondré
toute l'île de france a été touchée par
des rafales dépassant les 150 km heure
assez pour en verser un petit avion ou
transformer le bois de boulogne en champ
de bataille
la rafale la plus violente 173 km à orly
a failli coûter la vie à un chauffeur de
taxi au moment de charger dans ce coup
j'ai entendu deux cracs à la et de
là-haut et vient le temps de descendre
toute la toiture autre miracle sur les
champs elysées les grande roue installée
pour les festivités de l'an 2000 ont
tenu bon
il n'y a que de légers dégâts
c'est terrible les arbres qui sont
tombés sa barrière dans tous les sens
vous pouvez rien faire tant il fallait
attendre que tout se calme pour pouvoir
pouvoir faire quelque chose ici par
contre il n'ya plus qu'à constater le
désastre de ces cirques qui devait
ouvrir dans deux jours il ne reste que
quelques armature métallique
maigre consolation pour les forains une
telle tempête était pratiquement
imprévisibles sur paris les spécialistes
l'appelle déjà la tempête du siècle